I want to go over the most common forms
of meditation how each of them work what
benefits each bring and also who each of
them are for we will start off with
mindfulness breathing meditation how
does it work well basically you focus on
The Sensational breathing the feeling of
air going in your nose and out of your
mouth and whenever a thought appears you
simply notice it let it float away and
then you bring your attention back to
your breathing what sort of benefits
does this form of meditation bring now
mindfulness breathing meditation falls
under the scientific category of what's
called open awareness meditations where
you focus on becoming aware of your
thoughts and feelings these forms of
meditation have been shown to
drastically increase your levels of
creativity allowing you to come up with
many different ideas and solutions to
problems if you want to gain more
control over how sensitive you are to
negative thoughts and also how creative
you are then this might be the best form
of meditation for you follow us for more
helpful tips